hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
by now you've probably all heard of
Bitcoin crypto currencies and the
blockchain it's received a lot of press
lately Bitcoin Bitcoin bitcoins Bitcoin
Bitcoin Bitcoin it's all the rage but
what the hell is it in this video we'll
go over how these new systems compared
to regular currencies and also briefly
look at how they work I want to start
off this video is something that
happened recently it's the clip of the
Federal Reserve chairwoman Janet Yellen
getting grilled by Congress for the
Federal Reserve being shady as usual
this kind of thing is normal but in this
situation something unusual happens
watch closely
well we don't have a lack of
transparency I hear you can't audit it
there's a lack of transparency so I
regard the Federal Reserve is one of the
most transparent central banks in the
world we that's a state lien what this
is a great picture of the condition of
the old monetary world versus the
excitement of what could be the new
monetary world the blockchain and
cryptocurrencies came in the wake of the
frustration felt by the world after bad
monetary policies from central banks
like the Federal Reserve commercial
banks and hedge funds also had a large
part to play that just had to be another
way a way where people had control over
their own money again all right so to
begin what are crypto currencies broadly
speaking it is a form of currency that
is built on a global digital distributed
ledger called a blockchain
I'll get Luisa whom I met at the st.
Gallen symposium in Switzerland to
explain and then we'll break down the
terms that she says a bit later hi my
name is Louisa and I work as research
assistant at the texts and fiscal
department at the University of Graz in
Austria and the topic of my PhD is the
succession issues arising from the use
of cryptocurrency Bitcoin is is a crypto
currency as I say it's the most famous
crypto currency is not the only one but
it's becoming
more and more popular it was invented in
2008 for with the release of the white
paper by Satoshi Nakamoto which is the
inventor but it's still like unknown so
we don't really know who is this
characteristic of these cryptocurrency
so basically if I have to do an analogy
maybe for people easy search understand
it as the currency so something that you
use for paying services or goods but
it's very different because um the first
thing that seemed to arrive and find a
bit funny is that is decentralized so it
works with cryptography and in a network
composed by different computer as nodes
and is the centralized meaning that
there is no central bank or government
behind the currency or like in charge of
the monetary policy of this currency all
the transaction append are verified
through the network every transaction is
registering a led to a public ledger
which you can find online it's very easy
to to go through it and we just call the
blockchain so all the transactions are
recorded there you can see it before we
break things down it's important to note
that cryptocurrency is like Bitcoin and
theorem and others are distinctly
different from the digital fiat currency
in your bank account we'll take a look
at the differences using Bitcoin as an
example Bitcoin unlike a regular
currency has a cap supply of 21 million
coins in this way it's similar to gold
another finite resource that can be used
as money as time goes on the Bitcoin can
be divided up into smaller and smaller
units as the economy grows with
traditional digital fiat currency there
is no telling how much money is
circulating and no one knows if the
central banks will decide to start
printing more money this can be a real
problem depending on how you view
economics this is what I mean there are
two main schools of economics the
Austrian school and the Keynesian school
the Austrian school thinks that money
printing is a silent robbery by
inflation as it makes us poorer because
the more money there is the less it's
worth the Keynesian school actually
thinks inflation is a good thing in our
world most of the central bank's are
by Keynesian and today instead of
focusing on GDP growth and wealth
creation they focus on inflation they
actually want a steady-state inflation
of 2% per year in contrast Bitcoin and
other cryptocurrencies are deflationary
because there's a fixed amount making it
worth more over time instead of less so
why are these new digital currency is
called crypto currencies simply put it's
because they use a form of mathematics
called cryptography this allows
participants in the system to have a
unique address called a wallet kind of
like a bank account only the individual
has access to their wallet this personal
digital address or wallet mathematically
proves the money sent or received to
this wallet is actually going to the
right person
a wallet can be mathematically checked
for accuracy but can't be altered or
tampered in any way so what is a
blockchain in basic terms a blockchain
is a decentralized peer-to-peer system
in this system millions of computers
agree on a global record of the history
of all transactions that have ever taken
place in the system this global record
is called a ledger when you transfer
some money or a service on the
blockchain everyone in the system knows
about it if it's easier you can think of
it like another peer-to-peer service
like LimeWire or torrents where instead
of transferring files you're
transferring a transaction entry into a
very long notepad of all transactions
and the notepad can be seen by everyone
because there are millions of computers
keeping track of all the transactions
this makes it impossible to cheat and
create multiple fraudulent bitcoins the
computers that are looking after the
ledges and keep the system running a
coal miners they use their computers to
solve complex problems of how the
transaction should be put together each
time a problem is solved it's called a
block and each block holds ten minutes
worth of transactions and is put in a
chain when it's completed
hence the name blockchain the miners get
rewarded and cryptocurrency for their
efforts this is how new Bitcoin is
created this is all modeled on how gold
is mined out of the ground
since the activity of mining actually
costs electricity to do Bitcoin is seen
as
actual electronic unit of work by some
analysts will look at the blockchain in
the future video but this underlying
technology will be one of the most
influential inventions of this century
some analysts such as dan Tapscott are
putting its significance above that of
AI hailing it as a second internet but
much smarter the technology likely to
have the greatest impact on the next few
decades has arrived and it's not social
media it's not big data it's not
robotics
it's not even AI and you'll be surprised
to learn that it's the underlying
technology of digital currencies like
Bitcoin it's called the blockchain block
chain to give you an idea the etherium
blockchain is theoretically capable of
running entire companies and services
like Airbnb automatically with that
human input while also automatically
optimizing company performance the
blockchain also behaves as an automatic
auditor and accuracy check throughout
the whole system it's just part of how
the blockchain is designed in this way
Trust is actually built into the system
it all sounds crazy but as far as I've
looked into it I think it will have an
incredible impact on our world I'll be
getting dr. Adrian McCulloch one of the
world's leading experts and blockchain
technology law to talk with us in a
future episode okay so with that out of
the way what are some advantages of
crypto currencies because crypto is our
decentralized currency no central entity
regulates or controls it there is no
middleman
be it a bank government or any other
company with normal currencies when you
have a middleman they usually aggregate
power and aid in wealth inequality this
happens all the time today for example a
lot of the wealth created goes to those
closest to the financial industry banks
and those in the derivative markets etc
another advantage to being decentralized
is that as hard as to hack banks and
other centralized powers are an easy
target for hackers and have been hacked
in the past the blockchain on the other
hand is impossible to hack because to
hack just one block you must hack all
the previous blocks in that system's
history plus all the millions of
computers at the same time around the
world impossible with today's technology
but you may be thinking I've heard of
Bitcoin being hacked on the news the
hacking was actually at the exchanges
web sites where you can buy or sell
crypto currencies
this was the interface between the
blockchain and the normal internet the
actual blockchain has never been hacked
another advantage is that there's a low
barrier to entry anyone can join you
don't need a bank account or permission
from a government or any other entity or
even have to pay a fee all you need is
an internet connection and the software
this is great for a few reasons
it means that individuals in financially
oppressed countries such as China and
crisis countries such as Venezuela can
get their money out without being
tracked in contrast in today's currency
system it's hard to get your money out
in these situations for example the
Chinese government has been cracking
down on capital flight so worried
investors in China are buying
international property at any price just
as a way to store their currency of
course this causes other problems like
property bubbles in the countries that
they're buying property in addition to
this transferring cryptos
internationally is faster than
traditional methods taking ten minutes
instead of days because actually what is
positive about the blockchain
it's very efficient so in terms of costs
and how the transaction the transaction
are much faster than like if I want to
send some money to you you will take
from yours Australia yeah a couple of
days probably maybe one two days if
you're very lucky and it works very well
there is just like ten minutes so of
course it's it's much more efficient so
that's why I also like Marshall
send financial institution our exploring
option for other purposes so there are
all these discussions by learning music
another interesting advantage is because
the blockchain is transparent and
everyone in the system knows which
transactions are going to what wallet
cryptocurrencies can help stop
corruption in developing nations
so in conclusion it's clear that block
chain based currencies have some
attractive advantages over our regular
financial system a lot of governments
have taken interest and China has
actually announced that they're going to
be testing their own blockchain based
currency I must add that I'm not a fan
of a centralized government having
control over a cryptocurrency many banks
and companies are also implementing the
blockchain the city of Zurich in
Switzerland is actually implementing a
blockchain based ID system and there's
many many more stories around the world
of blockchain being implemented with
this all being said this area is just so
new that no one knows for sure what the
downsides could be yet just as an
example Bitcoin may fail due to some
unforeseen problem but I think
eventually there's gonna be a
cryptocurrency that's gonna get a right
whether you think this is a good or bad
thing there's no denying that the
blockchain and crypto currencies are
definitely going to shake things up this
video was just a bit of a teaser of
what's to come I'll be hoping to do a
lot more videos on this topic and go
into more detail about what's happening
with this revolution around the world
but before I go I guess there's a lot of
you that will be asking the question
should you invest in Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies well the answer depends
on you what are you actually looking for
are you in it for the long term are you
actually treating cryptocurrencies as a
store of value in case of a crisis much
like gold with this strategy people
usually just buy when the price goes
down but always accumulate more and
never sell until years later when they
want to get out
another group of people of the
speculators speculators are the ones
that just want to make quick cash this
is probably the hardest strategy because
cryptocurrencies are actually a real
free market not influenced by financial
instruments so it is going to be a wild
ride to do this successfully you'd have
to read all the news about the
cryptocurrencies that you're investing
in and know about the technical details
such as hard Forks you'd really have to
proceed with caution with this because
people that don't know what they're
doing are bound to buy and sell at the
wrong time are you in another category
where you're in a crisis country and
just need some financial freedom
obviously I'm not a financial adviser so
I can't tell you what category you
belong to or how to invest but I can
leave some resources for you to get
started in the description but anyway
there'll be much more on the cautionary
side of crypto investing when I speak to
dr. Adrian we both agreed that there is
a element of high PR and it's going to
be like another calm era where there'll
be a frenzy of investing a market crash
and only the real cryptocurrencies will
survive much like the googles and
Amazon's of the dot-com era so I guess
that's it thanks for watching this video
hope you got something out of it hope
you found it interesting this is a
really hot space at the moment and I
think we're really witnessing the
beginning of something this has been -
go go you're been watching cold fusion
if you need to this channel feel free to
subscribe cheers guys have a good one
and I'll catch you again soon for the
next video
[Music]
cold fusion
it's me thinking